economía en france 24 en el estudio me
acompaña daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida comenzamos el reino
unido y la unión europea están cada vez
más lejos de un acuerdo comercial post
praxis sin señor muy buenas noches raúl
pues el gobierno de boris johnson radicó
un proyecto de ley que le daría la
potestad de ignorar algunas partes del
acuerdo que de divorcio con la unión
europea esto es una especie de
declaración de guerra política ya que la
unión europea lo ve como una violación
del derecho internacional
gran bretaña abandonó el bloque de
países el 31 de enero sin embargo el
acuerdo exige un comercio libre de
fronteras en la isla de irlanda lo que
se está negociando raúl es como van a
ser las relaciones comerciales desde el
primero de enero del 2021
ahí es donde londres dice que si los
términos de lo que se negocia no le
favorecen está dispuesto a marcharse sin
cumplir lo que ya se ha pactado
y trabajo es defender la integridad del
reino unido pero también proteger el
proceso de paz de irlanda del norte y el
acuerdo del viernes santo y para ello
necesitamos una red de seguridad
jurídica para proteger a nuestro país
contra situaciones extremas o
interpretaciones irracionales del
protocolo que podrían conducir a una
frontera en el mar de irlanda
adiós y continuamos daniela porque
francia eeuu protagonizan una pelea de
gigantes del lujo si raúl y los
protagonistas son en la joyería
estadounidense tiffany y el grupo
francés louis vuitton ambas marcas muy
reconocidas en el mundo del lujo este
último iba a comprar a tiffany por
alrededor de 17 mil millones de dólares
y se habían puesto una fecha límite el
próximo 24 de noviembre pero el grupo
francés desistió raúl dijo no ya no la
quiero comprar lo interesante es que
esta pelea tiene un tinte político muy
vuitton dijo que el gobierno francés fue
el que le pidió retrasar la compra en
medio de la disputa comercial que tiene
ese país con
dos unidos tiffany respondió que no
existe ninguna base bajo la ley francesa
para que el ministro de relaciones
exteriores hor tenía una empresa que
incumpla un acuerdo válido y vinculante
y agrega que está más que claro que
louis vuitton tiene sus manos sucias el
tema de secuestrados judiciales en
delaware
tiffany demandó a su contraparte para
obligarla a sellar esta copa bueno le
damos a ver entonces qué pasó y el
gobierno en méxico expuso en su
presupuesto para el año 2021
bueno dice los expertos que se trata del
proyecto más austero del siglo 21 que
fue entregado hoy a la cámara de
diputados además no contemplan nuevos
impuestos ni subir los que ya están
este presupuesto contempla un aumento de
casi el 10 por ciento en inversiones en
salud también un alza del 5 por ciento
en proyectos de inversión de
infraestructuras sobre todo las obras
emblemáticas de andrés manuel lópez
obrador
todo esto encaminado a que haya un
crecimiento económico del 4 6% en 2021
ya que este año la caída que se espera
es del 8%
y en eeuu vive la oferta de vacantes de
empleo en julio si se estima que todavía
quedan más de 11 millones de plazas
laborales por recuperar para volver a
los niveles de antes de la pandemia y lo
está haciendo eeuu poco a poco sin
embargo las cifras son un poco
contradictorias raúl por un lado los
avisos clasificados que ponen las
empresas crecieron hasta 66 millones en
julio desde 6 millones en junio pero
esto no se reflejó en las contrataciones
que cayeron desde 7 millones hasta 5,8
millones en el mismo periodo lo cierto
es que hay una recuperación continua del
mercado laboral pero no al ritmo que se
necesita para recuperar la economía
daniela vamos ahora con los indicadores
bueno 'wall street' del cerro con
ganancias las que impulsaron fueron las
tecnológicas que justamente habían sido
las que habían arrastrado las grandes
pérdidas de las tres sesiones anteriores
como recordamos raúl las bolsas europeas
por su parte están muy pendientes de la
reunión de este jueves del banco central
europeo que podría anunciar estímulos
adicionales por
eso cerraron al alza también por todo lo
que hemos visto del break sit y en
américa latina bueno resultados sobre
todo en argentina cuya bolsa de comercio
de buenos aires avanzó más del 2 por
ciento y para finalizar que nos trae
como cifra el día son los casi 11 mil
millones de euros en pérdidas operativas
conjuntas que tuvieron los 17 mayores
grupos automovilísticos del mundo en el
segundo trimestre a causa de la pandemia
la única que en salva este es la una
cifra del día entonces muy roja
daniela muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica como siempre
ustedes también gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en france 24 continúe en
nuestra pantalla porque hay mucho más
para ver aquí en nuestro canal
[Música]